any fun behind-the-scenes memories from
dancing with the stars which we didn't
really talk about working um
you know what that was that had to be
nerve-racking it was i was just saying
that was not fun backstage it was it was
it was like it was like going in front
of a firing squad every week that's how
it felt it was nuts was it exciting it
was exciting and it was uh some weeks
were like triumphant because i was like
oh my god because i got i did get the
highest score a couple weeks which is
nuts because you lasted five rounds yeah
and i was the oldest um person for most
of the show wow which is nuts you know
and then i got most of the toys i got 50
well i i i i was 55 that's pretty old
all the other women were in their 20s
except for um mary wasn't and she got uh
she got cut the first week so it was
yeah and it was nuts and then i did i
got 54 of the 80 shows on tour and we
got cut short um a little bit
yeah but i did 45 of the shows so i only
missed attention which is not it's nuts
did you feel like you're in the best
shape of your life yes absolutely was it
was it were there times where you were
with your dance partner was named posh
posh pasha yeah were were there times
where you just felt like i can't do this
yeah i i can't i'm gonna yeah i
literally was like my body does not like
i i didn't i wasn't gonna quit but i was
like we gotta figure something out
because i'm not getting that step like
we i would love to and and again like i
wish i wish i'd had six months training
to get because i i was so out of shape
when we started i was not doing cardio
i'd put on a little weight and i was
like holy crap you know it's like i
literally said it is and i literally say
i did that show because i'm too cheap to
join a gym enough
i was like i want to be a negative
afraid but they weren't interested sorry
assistant they get it
but i actually it's but it was it was it
was an interesting challenge and it
almost becomes almost like a like a
religious practice where you just have
like it's the only thing you can focus
on there's not there's like nothing else
on the menu you just have to work on
that because otherwise
yeah lamar odom's uh dance partner was
screaming like that like two three like
bye
how long did he last uh
i think
two
three maybe two or three two or three
two three yeah because people just
wanted to see more yeah
i guess yeah but did you feel like you
were like hey i'm holding my own here i
did i did i did and i had another weird
i don't even know if we should talk
about this but my season sean spicer was
on and literally um the former president
was tweeting for people to uh vote for
sean so that's why he i
should have been on for at least one
more episode but sean
yeah so son of a bee isn't that weird it
is that administration literally was
affecting my it was very strange join us
every week as we discuss all that is
smallville we're going to watch every
episode that's right with you
talkville the ultimate smallville
podcast we're going to go way back join
tom welling and michael rosenbaum every
week as they rewind every episode of
smallville and discuss their experiences
with friends fans and co-stars talkville
the ultimate smallville podcast
you